fast unbemerkt entwickelt sich gerade
einen wettlauf in den weltraum als wir
gestern in einem kommentar vorgeworfen
wurde
ich würde beim vergleich spaceshuttle
dragon äpfel mit birnen vergleichen
habe ich mich ein wenig eingelesen und
erstaunliches festgestellt und dann kam
gestern noch die nachricht dass auch
indien zwei astronauten in den weltraum
schicken will ihnen aber gestern zum
ersten mal einen drei tonnen schweren
satelliten in den orbit gestartet wie
indien hätten wir dann bald vier
nationen die menschen ins all schicken
können 4 wie bitte jeder überwiegt bei
pixum zweiten sektion herzlich
willkommen
also erstmal was die ladekapazitäten
von space shuttle und dragon kapsel an
gitta zuschauer in limburg im grunde
recht aber auch nicht wehren brechen nur
knapp sechs tonnen befördern kann
konnte das spaceshuttle bis zu 24 anhalt
tonnen nutzlast transportieren
allerdings hat das space shuttle damit
nicht die internationale raumstation
erreicht der schub hat dafür nicht
gelangt zur iss im low earth orbit leo
also in eine niedrige erdumlaufbahn von
rund 300 metern höhe konnten die
shuttles lediglich 16 4 tonnen bringen
und da ist die welt hinein trägerrakete
von spacex die auch die sorgen
kaffeezeit es bringt den space aber
haushoch überlegen wie kann 22 8 tonnen
nutzlast in den neo transportieren es
hat sich einfach gezeigt dass das
eigengewicht eines space shuttles von
119 im wahrsten sinne des wortes ein
klotz am bein ist und die ladekapazität
nur selten wirklich benötigt wurde
kleinere kapseln bin da deutlich
günstiger und dann wurde ich neugierig
spacex hat nämlich eine weitere rakete
in planung die felton harry und deren
daten würden absolut beeindruckend wie
immer noch nicht so leistungsfähig wie
die natur und 5 rakete des
apollo-programms aber es geht langsam
wieder in diese richtung und das zu
deutlich reduzierten kosten während die
saturn fünf pakete 50 tonnen zum mond
schicken konnte ist die falcon heavy
immerhin in der lage knapp 64 tonnen zur
iss zu transportieren
wie wäre also in der lage große module
wie für eine raumstation in den low
earth orbit leo zu transportieren
in den geostationären orbit leo in
36.000 kilometern höhe immerhin noch
knapp 27 tonnen
und jetzt kommt's zum mars knapp 17 das
sind absolut beachtliche werte und sie
sagen eine menge über die
zukunftspläne von basic voraus und mit
dem flug von astronauten im weltall wird
ja nächstes jahr im mai wieder begonnen
darüber hatten wir ja im letzten video
berechnet damit wären die usa wieder im
club aber auch drei weiteren aktionen
neben den usa wollen oder schicken
bereits astronauten oder wie in china
reißt kein konnten ins all
achtung hier ein kleiner versteckte
hinweise satz also kurz zu ihnen die hat
man mit der gs lvm cup
die einst endlich eine trägerrakete die
menschen ins all transportieren kann
endlich muss man sagen denn zahlreiche
starts zuvor gingen schief und die
raketen flogen nicht ins all sondern in
den indischen ozean
weshalb die abkürzung aufhört seine
rally fila dem vehikel kurz generell
wegen des gefährts stand jetzt aber ist
der start eines mehr als drei tonnen
schweren satelliten gelungen innen ist
im wettlauf mit dabei russland ist
natürlich weiter im rennen und hat mit
dem focus und focus programm
der leistungsfähige und vor allem
kostengünstige systeme
denn das wird für die weiterentwicklung
der raumfahrt entscheidend sein
kostensenkung werden hier dazu führen
dass immer mehr möglich wird und eher
preiswerte charakteren staat werden
einen flug zum mars ermöglichen den
ansonsten kein land finanzieren könnte
aber kommen wir zum kleinen hinweis
gerade taikonauten wenn ihr am besten
bekommen von der rasanten entwicklung in
china kaum etwas mit und jetzt die bombe
china verfügt bereits über ein
weltraum labor in dem im letzten jahr
2000 einen monat experimente
durchführten wie dienen und jetzt kommt
s bombe zwei zur vorbereitung einer
eigenen raumstation und jetzt nochmal
achtung bombe drei die bereits 2022 also
in fünf jahre dienst aufnehmen und
diese aufenthalt im weltraum labor im
letzten jahr war erst der sechste
raumflug der schnee gelegen ein
wahnsinns tempo vor und werden dann wenn
sie an der iss beteiligten ländern
nicht noch eine idee haben ab
spätestens 2028 die einzige raumstation
im orbit und hätten damit die chance
den westen technologisch abzuhängen ob
sie aber jemanden schlag mit ich bin
sehr sehr sehr gespannt wie dieser
wettlauf weitergeht wird der westen hier
von china abgehängt und kann die
zukunft nicht mehr weltraumforschung und
auch die militärstrategen schauen ganz
gebannt nach asien sie fürchten die
vormacht china dem weltraum mit der sie
im kriegsfall schnell die oberhand über
den erdorbit und die satelliten dort
gewinnen könnten zwar sehen die
chinesen bringen ähnlich
naja dann schauen wir mal was ich in der
zukunft tut der wettlauf ins weltall
scheint jedenfalls sehr spannend zu
werden ich halte euch dazu natürlich
hier auf dem laufenden wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollte das wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke dann werdet ihr auch über
jedes video informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dem video über
weltraumtourismus geht es jetzt doch
schon los und ich sage bis dann bleibt